in this morning's eye on money a look at
some important financial planning
decisions
to consider during this pandemic look at
jerica holding it down as many teachers
prepare
to return to the classroom some are
really worried about making contingency
plans
i'm very concerned about going back to
school i'm very concerned about my
health
about my life and that's why my husband
and i decided to
write our wills
and it's not just an issue for teachers
before this pandemic a december survey
found that the number of americans
who have a will or other estate planning
documents has dropped
by nearly 24 since 2017.
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger says
not having a will is a big big big
mistake
she joins us to discuss why jill i know
from personal experience
after being how should we say harassed
by you i just mentioned in passing
i have a will but i have no idea where
it is you looked appalled and almost
fell off the chair and said you've got
to take care of that
so under jill's guidance i've contacted
a lawyer who you recommended she's great
i now have a will a fully proper will
but why is it so important to do that
regardless of your income regardless of
what you do
you know think of the will as your
instruction manual
when you pass away and it's so vital
that people know what your wishes are so
there are three basic documents
a will the legal instrument that
essentially says to the world
here's where my stuff goes and to whom
it goes but there are two other
documents that are so important right
now especially
one is called a durable power of
attorney that allows
somebody to act on your behalf for a
financial matter so
maybe if you're laid up and you're sick
you need to make a change in your
retirement account
or respond to a tax inquiry from the irs
and of course the health care proxy
which has become
so vital right now this will instruct
people to act on your behalf
with a health care decision these three
documents are the cornerstone
of every person's financial life
again if you don't do this it's totally
irresponsible
and you'll have me nudging you in the
back of your brain all the time
that's the word that got me jo when you
use the word irresponsible
i never want to be called irresponsible
and she used the i word when she was
talking to me
so what happens if you can't be there in
person to sign the papers a lot of us
can no longer do things
in person well i think that first off
when you talk to estate attorneys now
there are certainly places where you can
be
socially distant and masked and use your
own pen
to sign documents but if that is not an
option
there are some states that are allowing
video
signings now it's a little tricky every
state is different so you should check
with your attorney
but in that video signing you need to
have the printed document you have to
show the document
you've got to have the attorneys there
the counterparty's there
you have to have witnesses there you
have to have notaries there and then
everything has to get sent off to the
attorney's office so
this is incredibly important because if
you're going to do this let's do it the
right way
are there any other important legal
documents as we uh run out of time here
that you
you say that we must take care of at
this particular time and have available
i think amid the pandemic a few things
to remember when you once you have that
health care proxy
it's no good if somebody doesn't have
the document physically make sure
somebody either has the document printed
out who's your agent
or of course electronically you can have
it and for your older relatives
i would recommend pasting on the door
the inside door of your older relatives
homes or apartments
that health care proxy's name and
contact information
we have heard stories amid the pandemic
where people
come into the apartment they don't know
who to call and there are no documents
to be found so please
take this with a grain of salt when i
say to you i hope you never
need any of these documents anytime soon
but you
may so let's be clear
jill that's really good advice and your
phone number for people who need who
have more questions
ask jill at jillonmoney.com thank you
thank you jill schlesinger always good
to see you